j'étais très déçu et surpris à tel point
que vraiment je l'aï vraiment m'évanouir
confiné à une chaise roulante depuis la
tuerie et mondher ben ali estime que le
tireur s'en sort plutôt bien
il ne peut croire qu'après avoir
assassiné froidement si fidèle alexandre
bissonnette pourra demander une
libération après 40 ans j'aurais aimé
que que la justice soit rendue
toutes les victimes à ceux qui sont
décidés et que la sentence serait à à la
hauteur du crime perpétré
c'est une théorie c'est un attentat très
grave si ce n'est pas la colère qui nous
domine c'est la déception qui nous
domine et c'est l'espoir que cela va se
transformer en paix en dignité pour
toutes les personnes de ce type de cette
belle province
le juge françois huet a qualifié
d'absurdes l'imposition d'une peine qui
dépasse l'espérance de vie même dans le
cadre d'un tueur de masse tout être
humain doit être traité avec dignité et
respect a dit le juge johanne incluant
ceux qui par la violence commettre le
crime ultime d'enlever la vie à deux ou
plusieurs de leurs semblables
évidemment vous en douterez pâques nous
sommes déçus et surpris de la décision
aujourd'hui pour ne pas donner des
peines consécutives de 25,1 comme
l'espérait la communauté musulmane
le jeu est à interpréter plus largement
un article du code criminel
il ne remet pas en question l'imposition
de peines consécutives à un meurtrier
mais voulait se donner une marge de
manoeuvre pour donner une peine plus
appropriée à la situation de bissonnette
ont prague la décision du juge
aujourd'hui on va prendre le temps
d'analyser la décision en face une très
longue décision qu'on aura à décortiquer
ensemble il s'agit d'un jugement étoffé
qui nécessitera une analyse en
profondeur afin d'évaluer la possibilité
de porter le jugement en appel
pour les victimes et leurs proches la
question ne se pose même pas j'invite la
couronne de porter la cause en appel
parce que nous on est on est pas on
n'est pas contents de cette décision et
on refuse cette décision alexandre
ambitieux net n'a pas eu vraiment de
réaction une fois qu'il a reçu sa peine
il a ajouté un bref coup d'oeil vers ses
parents dans la salle d'audience avant
de quitter vers les cellules où il devra
rester au moins jusqu'à ce qu'il ait
atteint l'âge de 67 ans et s'il yannick
bergeron radio-canada au palais de
justice de québec